mano solo les gitans
et
m
il fait beau pour sol est sur le pont je
regarde les gitans de l'autre côté du
port ils sont beaux ici je ne dois pas
leur tête
ils sont juste
mon oeuvre
ensemble devant la caravane
à s'agiter autour de leur conversation
il doit parler franc genre entend des
bribes par dessus
voiture la présence rien sur ma peau
on sent qu'il n'existe pas quoi
et
c'est pas comme l'autre qui vient avec
sa porsche surveiller son petit voilier
ni même comme les plans tordus pompiers
veilhan la résignation d'ailleurs son
parti était bien à cause des gitans
une petite boule rouge s'activent autour
du groupe maintient un ballet qui fait
deux fois sa taille
je venais pas il ment c'est sec de la
manche qui vole au dessus de sa tête
changer les critères
si ça tombe jusqu'aux pieds au faux
papiers
roland briand
on savait de quoi tu as
oh
je t'avais pas ce tableau
mais j'ai gardé pour moi cette lettre
cette journée qui vous ça peut me faut
tombant jusqu'aux qu au mal comme un
cerf-volant 28 ans dans le soleil de
printemps
soleil de trois temps
mano solo chanteur de pain